combustible a precio de costo esta
estación de gasolina no necesitaba más
argumentos para atraer conductores
durante la primera semana de octubre de
2021 en francia el diesel alcanzó un
máximo histórico de 153 euros por litro
en promedio para la gasolina sin plomo
95 un euro y 63 centavos una media muy
cercana al récord en 2012 entonces a
este precio hasta el más mínimo ahorro
es importante es pilar l ahí son 161
euros de camino al lado de brétigny es
167 a 170 eso hace una diferencia al
llenar el tanque una gran diferencia por
mi trabajo hago 80 mil kilómetros al año
así que si eso es mucho entonces para mí
un aumento de 10 centavos al final del
año se vuelve caro los precios en el
surtidor siguen el precio del barril de
petróleo que se ha recuperado
bruscamente con la recuperación
económica mundial y los suministros aún
limitados de ciertos países productores
para hacer frente al aumento de los
precios del combustible el primer
ministro francés yann castex anunció una
indemnización para 38 millones de
franceses nunca lo decide de un soft
vamos a decidir sobre una especie de
subsidio de inflación de 100 euros que
se pagará a los franceses del pse of es
un subsidio de clase media en cierto
modo casual e singular que el curso a
los que ganan menos de dos mil euros
netos al mes net pago según el gobierno
esta ayuda se pagará automáticamente a
partir de diciembre y sin distinción
entre conductores y usuarios de otros
medios de transporte
demasiado poco demasiado tarde según la
oposición que denuncia un gesto político
sin impacto real para quienes sufren el
aumento de combustibles esta inflación
se suma a una crisis energética que está
sacudiendo el poder adquisitivo de los
franceses y haciendo que el ejecutivo
teme el resurgimiento de un movimiento
social a gran escala tras el aumento de
los precios del gas se anunció un
bloqueo hasta abril finalmente será
efectivo durante todo el año 2022 según
anunció el primer ministro